y'all it is seriously gross out in DC
today but I still want to get my flow on
so this actually might be a good
opportunity for me to talk about how we
can get our flow on in smaller indoor
spaces during the colder months Drex
here from drexfactor POI sharing with
you the love of poi spinning and flow
Arts to benefit your body and brain and
today we're going to be exploring how we
can keep those bodies and brains working
during the colder months even and
especially if you don't have a lot of
space to work in but before we do that I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys and Ultra POI for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all of these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that I have down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca pakonen thank you so
very much for supporting my Channel my
work and my mission so I've already
talked a bit about bundling up during
the colder months to go out and flow but
there are just going to be some times
when the weather's not cooperating maybe
there's a lot of precipitation maybe
it's super windy what have you and in
those cases we kind of have to make do
with the spaces that we have access to
so I want to share with you all five of
my best tips for making your flow work
in indoor spaces no matter how big or
small during the colder months groovy so
I'm going to set up my camera on a
tripod so you can see me work
all right so first and foremost uh I
feel like it's a little bit gloomy in
here so let me turn some lights on see
if we can fix that a little bit yeah
sweet yeah that that helps a lot let me
uh cool perfect so
first things first
um I know I have a lot of space in here
uh more than most but I also am going to
say that I would like to have a little
bit more so it's going to lead us to tip
number one uh do what you can to clear
out the clutter in your space so um
anything that you might accidentally hit
move out of the way anything that might
be a little bit delicate Maybe cover it
up with something that's got a little
bit of padding to it let me get to work
here this can live over here this
can go back here might not be a bad idea
to put a little bit of padding on the TV
give me one second
yeah awesome I think that'll work well
all right I'm loving all that space cool
now then I need to pick out a set of poi
so that takes us to tip number two so
because when we spin indoors there are a
plethora of objects that might take some
damage due to colliding with a set of
poi that is heavier or harder I'm going
to make the choice to go ahead and spin
with POI that are a little bit softer
and a little bit lighter both to
preserve the environment as well as
myself here so I think that is going to
point me towards starting off with a set
of sock POI they are wonderfully soft
especially in these little heads right
here they give me a lot of options to
work with and even better they show up
well on camera so you'll note I also
made a choice right off the bat there
that takes us to tip number three and
that is because we're dealing with a
smaller space indoors I usually shorten
up my POI I can do this by wrapping them
around my hand once or wrapping them
around around the first two fingers this
just basically lets me work inside of a
smaller space without having to
significantly adjust the the length of
my arms in order to do so
[Music]
thank you
now because I'm also dealing with the
shortened ceilings I'm also having to
make a choice in terms of the amount of
volume that I take up this takes us to
tip number four that is when indoors
it's probably best to switch to an
orientation where you are having a
little bit more give in your elbows
um I I hate to use this term but we're
going to use it here this is a place
where you're allowed to use T-Rex arms
and maybe not extend your arms out the
entire way as you're spinning the POI
when you get back outside you can go to
full extension and believe me I invite
you to do so you know I think because
it's so gloomy I'm feeling doing some
Led POI today I think I have my pod POI
over here all right so these are kind of
the best of all worlds not only are they
pretty light as well as soft but also by
default they're a little shorter so I
have a little bit more freedom to extend
my arms but not a whole lot there
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so this will take us to tip number five
which is that there are actually schools
of spinning that are specifically geared
to spinning in spaces that are a little
bit smaller that don't have enough as
much uh ceiling or side clearances you
may like the whole point of glow
stringing is to try and spin objects in
as small a space as possible so if
you're not already during the colder
months might be a great opportunity to
work on some of your glow stringing
technique to play around with those
shotguns with those wraps with those
spiral wraps and seeing what comes out
of that oh you know what else uh is a
great use for smaller spaces I've been
learning some basic uh Maori short POI
technique in the past few weeks and
definitely this works well inside of
small spaces for sure expect to see
several videos on this topic to drop in
the coming months by the way
[Music]
all right so I think what I'm actually
feeling right now is to go ahead and
just do a little dancey dance with my
LED POI right now so I'm going to go
ahead and put on some music and just
flow out for a little while if you want
to uh join me please do
[Music]
everybody
foreign
[Music]
really really good thank you all for
joining me for that Journey
um what are some of your tips for
spinning indoors during the Colder
Weather months uh leave me a comment let
me know and also let me know did any of
these tips help you out please make sure
to like comment share and subscribe to
keep the conversation going and to help
other people find this video
foreign
would not be possible without the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your amazingly
generous support if you out there
watching would like to support either me
or the channel there are three great
ways that you can do that right now
number one you can head on over to
patreon.com directs factorpoi and sign
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards and even better
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring POI spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world go check that out
please and thank you number two you can
take one of my courses over at
learn.drexfactor.com I have beginner
intermediate and advanced courses
available over there that will take you
through the basics as well as some of
the stuff that goes beyond the basics
and even Advanced POI technique once
again go check that out over at
learn.drexfactor.com finally you can
take one of my live stream classes these
have a focus on Dance and relearning POI
from the ground up you can sign up for
whichever is the current session or the
next session coming up over at
crowdcast.io
drexfactor please note all of those
classes are recorded so you can watch
them whenever you so choose if you want
to watch more videos where I talk about
how we can spend during the colder
months I'm going to include a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here so maybe give
that a look as well thanks so much for
watching make sure to float today
whether it is inside or outside and I
will see you with a brand new video real
soon take care and have a good one peace